If Hillary Clinton wins the presidency, if
she will be the first female president in
America, what would you expect from her as
president?
Well, in America, it's not the president - it's
an institution.
So of course, she will make history as a woman.
I wouldn't say that I am happy, but I hope
that she can really prove to be the woman
that I think of - but I doubt that very much,
because again, she has to play the political
game within the American institution, within
the American system.
She has been playing it in the past and she
will be playing it in the future, but nevertheless,
at least I'm sure I would like Mrs. Clinton
more than Mr. Trump in America.
But for us, I'm hoping that she as a woman,
understanding that she is a powerful advocate
of women in third-world countries and she
has been doing great work in that field.
So I do hope that we can see a woman who can
have an impact on the global chaos that's
going on now, today, and that she brings good
people and is surrounded by people that have
an intelligent new vision about this world,
and that she [does what she promises].
I was in America last week, in New York, and
to be very honest with you, the debate is
very fierce against Mrs. Clinton.
You know, Benghazi, she also has a lot of
history behind her.
So I want to wait and see, because we were
happy with Mr. Obama when he came to power,
but then he disappointed us, heavily disappointed
us.
So I don't know if this politician, at this
age, being trapped in this political system
that's bringing chaos to the globe, leading
us to more wars, to more blood...
And I hope also to see that these international
institutions keep their promises and change
these people and bring the youth to the forefront.
I'm for the younger generation, only the younger
generation can bring the innovative ideas.
It's fantastic what the youth is trying to
do in Libya.
Fantastic.
But who is giving them the chance, who is
listening to them?
Or the women, who are all... away.
Because we think, and if you think correctly,
of course, if you are a woman, if you think,
if you are corageous, well, you have the wrong
recipe.
They told me here at the EU!
Many people don't want to meet me, I'm too
straightforward, I'm too much of an activist,
I'm not a diplomat - no thank you, I don't
want to be a diplomat!
What's a diplomat - to sit, listening to you,
insulting my people, insulting my country,
and you want me to be quiet?
No!
I'm not interested in staying in Brussels,
staying in the EU.
Of course, I will always be, hopefully, cooperating
with other departments for the benefit of
my country within the EU.
But if it's done wrong, I don't think that
I will be happy to...
I've been within this international circle,
I've been very close within the UN community
for 30 years, I know the corridors of this
UN system inside out.
They have to change, there must be pressure
internationally.
They have to know the game is over, they cannot
continue to contribute to this disaster in
the globe, and the European and Western taxpayer,
they are the one who have the responsibility
to question them.